I think that the people who run
organizations do have a great deal of
personal accountability and the
regulations have changed in recent times
to make that very clear whether at the
end of the day negligence is going to be
the cause of some sort of criminal
liability time will tell
it's very difficult to pinpoint it's not
usually a single person who's the cause
of a problem it's at over period things
get wrong and you say oh well is it
today bad and you think no we can do
this and that and then that turns out
not to be right so it's over a long
period and lots of fingers are on
fingerprints are on the problem so I
probably wouldn't go as far as to say
that people who run companies badly are
criminally liable but they certainly
personally liable do you think that's
banks and all other financial
institutions are still too big to fail
though this too big to fail is such a
phrase isn't it I think that we go
through cycles of organisations you
become very big and they extend out of
their areas of expertise and I think
that's always very dangerous and a point
I'm trying to get across is if you are
running a large organization who amongst
the non-executive directors actually
understands the business you're in do
they simply write rely on the executive
team to tell them but you also need non
exec directors who are highly conversin
tin the management of crises all
organizations all large organizations
will have crisis exercises and tests how
often does a non-executive director
actually attend those and even if they
did would they know had they been in a
crisis because that's where you need to
have the expertise on the ball you've
also said that you think non exec
directors should be working something
like 150 days a year
I mean that makes it a full-time job
doesn't it yes exactly but in large
organisations which operate all over the
world in many types of businesses you
you need to be able to spend time in
those businesses meeting the executives
who are making the decisions I don't
think you can do that in 30 or 40 days a
year
it's just too extensive at Lloyds Bank
we operated in 40 countries you know how
how do you get across to even the big
ones unless you're working well over 100
days a year you're going to have fewer
people wanting to be non execs under
those circumstances there aren't you I
don't see why that is the case I know I
don't see why that is the case I think
that the non-executive director
population at the moment may not be up
for that but there's plenty of other
people out there who may well be
disposed to doing that